salut aujourd'hui on va parler boîtier
numérique on va parler cannon parce que
cameron s'apprête à sortir un nouveau
boîtier le canon ef 77 dès qu'il sera le
petit frère du 90 je sais pas ce qui
intéresse à cannes en mai en tout cas de
80 des c'est vraiment un appareil qui
est extraordinaire pour faire de la
vidéo notamment du globe la vidéo sur
youtube
c'est vraiment un super appareil parce
qu'il a plein de possibilités tu as déjà
un écran qui peut se tourner comme tu
avais sur le six ans et qui était un
vieux vieux boîtier qui a quelques
bonnes années mais qui marche encore
toujours et du coup se 77 des va voir
plein de fonctionnalités un processeur
plus puissant que les 90 mais surtout
sera beaucoup moins cher et beaucoup
plus pratique pour les débutants donc on
va commencer à en parler et je vais
détailler un petit peu et expliquer
pourquoi si tu fais de la vidéo et que
tu débutes est pas un expert un grand
champion tu peux carrément débuté sur
l'a77 des qui coûtera moins cher qu'un
90 et tu vas voir que franchement il a
des avantages qui sont non négligeables
et pour l'instant on va commencer un
film avec ce boîtier là alors ça c'est
pas le 77 des jeux l'est pas il n'est
pas sorti et j'ai pas de proto par
contre ça c'est un 5d mark iii qui a un
excellent boitier qui m'a été prêté qui
n'est pas à moi et on va changer l'atout
de fitch est en train de filmer avec mon
osmo plus de dj on va changer on swiss
là dessus et on va voir s'il imaginait
york après un deux trois donc tu vois ça
n'a rien à voir là je vienne changer je
suis sûr en 50 directement dont canon 5d
mark iii mon objectif c'est 1,50
ça change complètement l'ouverture et
c'est totalement différent mais c'est
super bien moi j'adore ces images je
trouve vraiment très très belle bon tu
vois après effectivement on a moins
d'ouvertures les choses sont un peu
différentes mais peu importe ça c'est ce
qui s'appelle se planter c'est à dire
que en réalité quand on regarde la vidéo
j'étais un peu flou parce que le point
était fait devant moi donc j'ai fait
cette connerie et c'est là l'intérêt sur
les cannon d'avoir un écran parce
qu'avec l'écran tu vois et quand tu
l'islande direct tu vois très bien si tu
es flou s'était pas floues pas lasser en
cinq derrière l'écran tu peux pas le
bouger
ce qui fait qu en réalité j'étais
aveugle j'étais en train de tourner ne
vous rendez pas compte de ce que je
tournais et je voyais pas si ça allait
mais si ça allait pas la preuve en est
c'est pas beau le point il est devant
chez eux un peu flou dans les quelques
plans après tu vas voir je vais
m'avancer ça sera beaucoup plus clair
bon tu m'entends le message est là c'est
plus clair voilà donc
excuse moi on y retourne c'est parti
pour en revenir aux 77 des che cannon
qui va sortir normalement au mois
d'avril 2010 est c'est un bout éthique
qui va être légèrement différent du 80
des 80 des qui était le boîtier de
l'année 2016 de l'année dernière et qui
est vraiment un excellent boîtier donc
si tu veux faire de la vidéo le 77 des
îles à plein davantage le premier c'est
d'être plus compact et plus léger que le
92 pour la prise en main ça va être
sympa ça c'est le point numéro un
techniquement c'est sensiblement la même
chose tu vas avoir 20 devait avoir 24 2
millions pixels que ce soit le 77 des où
que ce soit 90 il ya une petite
différence sur le processeur parce que
le 80 des processeurs plus anciennes
générations mais qui va toujours très
bien c'est le dixel de digix 6 et le 77
des alleux digix est ces nouveaux
processeurs qui va équiper les nouveaux
boîtiers de kanon 45 collimateur pour la
mise au point pour 77 comme pour le 90
l'autofocus c'est la même chose c'est un
mauvais ce duel pixels ça change
absolument rien qui marche très très
bien
les deux films en full hd en 60 images
seconde
on attend vraiment que cannes on passe
enfin le chemin de la 4k qui se
proposaient des films enquête car pour
l'instant c'est pas encore le cas mais
on pense que ça va arriver dans les
années à venir parce que la cac est en
train de se démocratiser
il ya des télex en 4k on peut diffuser
des vidéos en 4k sur youtube alors
effectivement aujourd'hui n'y a pas
assez de bande passante encore tout le
monde n'est pas en fibres pour la télé
c'est pareil tout le monde n'a pas télé
cap kaino trouve quelque chose qui va
vraiment se démocratiser et on attend
vraiment que cannon nous emmène de la
capca ça c'est encore un peu le regret
bon tu me diras tout de suite c'est pas
bien grave parce que de toute façon en
filmant en full hd en 1080p
ça fonctionne très bien 60 images par
seconde c'est bien tu feras pas des
ralentis dingue mettons à quelque chose
de super et tu pourras ralentir un petit
peu ton image c'est relativement
convenable mais là où le 77 des pros
passe quelque chose de vraiment nouveau
c'est une stabilisation stabilisation
dans cinq plans là où 80 des était déjà
un superbe outil et avait un
stabilisateur intégré le 77 des va
beaucoup plus loin avec leur nouveau
stabilisateur ski sécu pour les plans où
tu vas légèrement tremblé ça va
complètement l'amortir et ça normalement
tu l'auras prix j'ai hâte de pouvoir
l'essayer tester parce que moi c'est
pour ça que j'étais parti sur regarde
moi je filme avec ça l'intérêt que tu
vas avoir directement sur un haussement
ou l'asmo plus moi ça doit me plus c'est
que tu vois quand tu tiens empoigné c1
steadicam alors là il est éteint mais
normalement
fixe et je peux t'assurer que car d'une
stabilité de dingue si un cannon arrive
à se rapprocher alors ça sera jamais un
steadicam sauf si effectivement tu
prends ton cannon et tu prends des
solutions de stabilisation type
steadicam là effectivement tu l'as marck
chose de très stable mais par contre
pour des choses que tu vas prendre au
point le tenir sur un petit tripode elle
déplacé avec une vraie stabilisation
ça va vraiment faire des images qui
seront beaucoup plus propre et c'est
pour ça que le 77 des à mon avis est
vraiment géniale pour la vidéo on
revient sur l'osmose je vais te montrer
un petit peu j'ai vu deux ou trois trucs
sion de m il ya déjà il ya des images de
ce boîtier il faut que tu vois ça me
paraît quand même relativement important
et puis j'ai vu des choses un peu
différentes dont je souhaite te parler
qui sont vraiment super tu vas voir
allez viens on se connecte on va
regarder directement sur le web le
boîtier est magnifique il paraît
beaucoup plus compact que celui que moi
j'ai en main que le 5d qui est quand
même beaucoup pouvons donc prenez des
photos bon ça pour les pour la
photographie moi je veux plus parler
vidéo ça c'est ce que je te disais on
n'est plus là dessus
alors hop le nouveau processeur 45
collimateur pour l'auto focus le capteur
24,2 millions de pixels c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure
donc la photographie c'est très bien on
passe qui tu rates un coup d'oeil sur le
site net à l'adresse un canyon point fr
tu pourras aller voir directement là tu
as bien effectivement toujours
l'autofocus cm odua de pixels que tu
avais déjà sur le 80 des en vidéo les
time lapse times où vit ça c'est
vraiment très très bien et surtout
d'utiliser la stabilisation numérique
sur cinq axes ça je pense que c'est
vraiment un truc extra et ça va apporter
beaucoup j'ai vraiment hâte de l'essayer
hâte de découvrir voir comment ça marche
donc pour les photos bon bah je te passe
après c'est un boîtier là tu vois très
bien pu teint utilisation tu peux
directement le brancher à ta tablette
que ce soit de l'android ou de laïos tu
peux le mettre directement dessus
l'intérêt il est super simple c'est
qu'en fin de compte déjà ça te fait un
moniteur tu peux mettre en boîte un peu
plus loin même si tu as le petit écran
rétractable pendant ce qui se passe là
cette femme moniteur à distance tu peut
déclencher à distance et tu peux voir ce
qui se passe à distance ça déjà fait
extra et en plus de ça tu peux partager
tes photos directement sur cloud tu peux
les envoyés de faire pas mal de choses
donc ça apporte vraiment ils sont
vraiment encore dans le côté
connectivité et puis voilà un faire
marcher les deux vice ensemble c'est
vraiment l'intérêt et je trouve que là
dessus sans faire tout ce qui est
vraiment bien tu peux le faire en wifi
tu peux aussi le faire en bluetooth donc
tu vois ça évolue c'est quand même
relativement sympa là on est sur le site
le monde de la photo qui te présente
également le bottier indirectement alors
tu ne vois pas le dessus tu le vois
devant tu vois un peu de tous les côtés
tu vois à l'écran c'est le même écran
lcd que tu avais 190 donc on ne cherche
pas
c'est la même chose écran tactile
toujours donc ça c'est aussi vraiment
très sympa pour faire un autofocus
pourtant pas mal de choc
toutes ces options dessus satellite da
les tribunes et les boutons et c'est en
ça que ce boîtier est vraiment adapté
aux débutants et en plus la navigation
et le menu interne est complètement
différent ils ont fait quelque chose qui
vraiment adapté aux débutants
en fait si tu veux c'est une nouvelle
interface et une nouvelle interface qui
vraiment adapté aux vidéastes débutants
comme aux photographes débutants les
choses sont très très visuel et tu
comprends l'intérêt de telle ou telle
fonctionnalité
en réalité c'est extrêmement intuitif et
c'est en ça que ce boîtier est vraiment
novateur alors là il te le monde sur le
800d mais c'est exactement la même chose
en 77 des c'est à dire que tu as
vraiment sa patte à face là sur laquelle
tu peux naviguer facilement
donc c'est complètement tactile tu va
déplacer directement avec ton doigt les
paramètres quels que soient les
paramètres et tu vas pouvoir
effectivement comprendre directement
avec des illustrations à quoi
correspondent les paramètres que tu
manipules donc pour la vidéo cas pas
nécessairement besoin de trifouiller à
fond tous les paramètres mais en tout
cas c'est vraiment extrêmement
intéressant pour la vidéo type optimisé
pour la prise de photos tu peut
optimiser et voilà donc c'est un
appareil qui est vraiment facile de
prise en main qui est facile à
comprendre facile à configurer et qui a
énormément davantage
en gros on peut dire si tu veux que le
canot noël 77 décès la version
simplifiée et allégée du 80 des est
aussi beaucoup moins cher la houle 80
des écoutes à peu près 1200 euros le 77
des devrait coûter 899 a pris 1 900
euros
donc voila un petit peu ce qu'on peut
dire aujourd'hui si tu es sur ce nouveau
boîtier de canal je pense que ça va
cartonner alors ça prendra jamais la
place
d ça n'a pas la prétention de le faire
et de toute façon va pas faire la même
chose mais par contre pour les gens qui
veulent un petit boîtier pas très cher
sur lequel on peut débuter soit en photo
soit en vidéo et se lancer à faire de la
vidéo sur youtube je pense que c'est
vraiment un super boîtier d'autant plus
que tu peux adapter tous les objectifs
qu'elles n'ont pas plein de possibilités
tu pourras faire des images différentes
et ça c'est génial
tout simplement dis moi ce que t'en
pense je sais pas si toi tu es un fan de
kanon est ce que tu fais déjà des vidéos
sur youtube ce que tu envisages de le
faire si oui quel équipement tu as quel
équipement tueur au visage alors qu'est
ce que tu penses de ce boîtier est ce
que tu penses que par rapport aux 81
d'oeil à sa place ou est-ce que ils se
superposent réellement qui a pas
vraiment d'innovation mais moi tous tes
commentaires pour nous vraie discussion
et puis qu on échange là-dessus n'hésite
pas aussi c'est un petit moment à
regarder cette vidéo qui était aussi
très sympa abonne toi et puis je te dis
à très bientôt et merci tiens je te
laisse le canyon dix ans le mot de la
fin
salut